hey this is um
this is really a disgusting story
not only
of
media propaganda
but also in a sense of media
consolidation
reuters has done a very very good
special report about how the radical
outrageous right-wing media network oan
one america news the people we would see
in the press briefing room yelling
questions from the back at trump and
even to jen saki to some degree
they are 90 percent funded by a t the
same a t
who bought warner media which owns cnn
so
this story is about a lot of different
things
the report on reuters is extensive and
we're linking to it
okay
we
today for time purposes are going to
look at sort of a summary from mediaite
of the reuters investigation
okay
uh one american news the self-styled
news channel that pumps out pro-trump
propaganda
has received tens of millions of dollars
in funding from at t according to a
stunning new report
reuters unearthed how the far-right
channel which distinguished itself in
cable news by peddling the most extreme
2020 election conspiracy theories is
being propped up by the world's largest
communications company a reuters review
of court records shows the role at t
played in creating and funding oan a
network that continues to spread
conspiracy theories about 2020 and covid
the role that at t played in the launch
of oan was revealed by the network's
founder robert herring senior in a
deposition obtained by reuters quote oan
founder and chief executive robert
herring senior has testified that the
inspiration to launch oan in 2013 came
from came from at t executives they told
us they wanted a conservative network
they only had one which was fox news and
they had seven others on the other left
wing side when they said that i jumped
to it and built one since then at t has
been a crucial source of funds flowing
into oan providing tens of millions in
revenue court records show
90 percent of oan's revenue came from a
contract with at t owned tv platforms
including directv
what makes this bizarre tale even
thornier atnc owns warner media which is
the parent company of cnn
cnn's parent company is funding o-a-n
and again i encourage you to check out
the entire reuters report so there are i
mean there are so many stories here guys
first of all
maybe anti-trust laws are there for a
reason maybe we should be having more
than just a handful of internet service
providers who are vertically integrated
and also own the programming okay that's
that's number one we have many of these
laws on the books there's been no
appetite from republicans or democrats
really in enforcing this stuff you do
hear sometimes from democrats we got to
break up this that the other thing we've
heard it from bernie elizabeth warren
not uh
nearly the topic that it should be
that's one story
second story
cnn
has done a bunch of critiques of oan
okay they they've exposed oan's lack of
journalistic integrity and they did it
accurately
um
does cnn know when they do that
that the parent company is the same
they're owned by warner which is owned
by at t and uh a t is it's not owned but
is the main funder of oan
it wasn't mentioned in the segments that
were done on cnn makes me wonder whether
they even know it if either way you
would think it's something that should
be disclosed now full disclosure it
appears as though
a t
also owns this show no i'm kidding
that's not the type of disclosure i'm
talking about it appears as though a t
is in the process of selling warner
media so at some point the cnn oan
connection may no longer be true
uh but this is another example also of
how we have to remember
the primary bias of corporate media
is money
msnbc
is corporate media
and editorially they lean left
fox news is corporate media editorially
they don't just lean right i mean fox is
on the right something different than
what msnbc is on the left cnn
has been
anti-trump i would say objectively so
because of the disasters trump did
during his presidency but fundamentally
cnn is a for-profit entity and that's
the number one bias above all else
and um we have to remember that a lot of
this stuff
the technology
for delivering this stuff becomes
invisible and we just look at oh it's
you know uh rachel maddow here and then
it's hannity here we've got to remember
the technology has its own biases and
structure that kind of overrides all of
this other stuff and at t we've got
stuff that's considered more left and
stuff that's considered basically we
just want to be able to monetize all
these different things that's the bottom
line and um whether ultimately we will
see any serious enforcement of antitrust
i don't know
uh but there is certainly
you know the the problem is
that even now that republicans talk
about antitrust and breaking up
companies
they're really just wanting to break up
social media or control social media so
that twitter can't ban conservatives
like it's completely cynical
their newfound desire to deal with
antitrust the laws have been on the
books for decades could have been
enforced all along and they just don't
want to do it so we're we'll see what
happens read the report from reuters on
a t funding
oan we'll post a link to it in the
description to the youtube video and
we'll be back right after this
let's be honest most health food snacks
are not very exciting they don't taste
great they don't fill you up
one of our sponsors is monk pack who
makes amazing keto granola bars that are
sweet soft chewy and filling with a
slight crunch each has only one gram of
sugar two to three net carbs and just
140 calories perfect for anybody doing
low carb or keto or if you just want a
tasty sweet snack without the sugar
everybody should be mindful of sugar
intake but you don't have to do so at
the expense of flavor because monk pack
keto granola bars come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip peanut
butter blueberry almond vanilla there
are other flavors too i can tell you
firsthand they're all great i always
keep these in my pantry it's a perfect
snack during a busy day go to
monkpack.com
link underneath this video and you'll
save 20 when you use the promo code
pacman at checkout